I'm about to start a ten-city book tour
for physics of the future I'll be
traveling to Boston New York Washington
DC Chicago Los Angeles San Francisco
Seattle Portland Minneapolis but let's
say that you can't make it let's say
that you don't live next to one of these
great metropolitan centers well you can
be part of the excitement first of all
if you're a member of Facebook you can
go to facebook.com slash 2100 physics or
if you're on Twitter and you want to
find out what the excitement is about
what the reaction to the book tour have
been go to at 2100 physics in addition I
have my own Twitter site you can go to
at michio kaku that's one word mich i
okay aku and you can follow me as i do
interviews as I give lectures as I share
my enthusiasm with all the fans that are
out there and let's say that you want to
enter some of the numerous contests
where we're offering free copies of
physics of the future here's what you do
if you want to be part of the numerous
contests we're offering when you Twitter
a statement end it with hashtag 2100
physics
once again hashtag that's symbol with a
cross 2100 physics at the end of your
Twitter statement that's how you can be
part of the numerous contests we're
offering and you could win a copy of
physics of the future